it is time for drew's news your daily
spritz of the oh to good news
and with me at the desk
is the best smelling man in news it's
rossy ross math well thank you so much
for noticing thank you hi everybody
we're coming in hot today with the photo
that's sparking massive internet debate
okay the new york post reports that a
british man named darren dowling
recently shared a pic of what his hotel
room looks like when he's finished with
it you seeing that little camping trip
he's set up there
all right well before he checks out he
strips the bed and leaves everything in
little piles
this blew me away i i i feel like i'm a
pretty good human being right you are
thank you i know you you are but i've
never done that
when you leave that's the nicest thing
should we all be doing this drew do you
do this i've never stripped the bed but
i have an obsession
and it is cleaning hotel rooms before i
check out
um i will not leave them dirty if i if
there are towels i can pile them
i make the bed even if it's just sort of
like you know it doesn't have to be
hospital corners levels because i know
it's going to get undone again you know
i'm not really surprised by this at all
drew and in fact i have some evidence
you don't even know about this but this
is you in 2014 in a hotel room
chris miller our executive producer sent
these to us you had spilled makeup on
the carpet and before you checked out
you got a vacuum and
cleaned it all up
and you were pregnant on your hands and
knees on that floor in the hotel room
well um i mean that also just shows my
other obsession which is stain removal i
don't know
if that just shows how insane i am
um and that my stand for stain segment
on the show is you know really true it's
not an act i am obsessed i just cannot
bear the idea
of housekeeping walking in and not
seeing that level of gratitude and
respect i so appreciate that that being
said i'm not going to start stripping
beds at hotel room and i'll tell you why
because every time i go to sleep in one
i think to myself don't think about what
happened on this bed before you got here
don't think about what happened
and i certainly if i don't want to think
about it then i certainly don't want to
pull the sheets off and see it right
so as much as i want to be a good person
uh siri
not sorry we took an instagram poll
and asked have you ever stripped the
hotel bed and it was a resounding no
okay 23
stripped the bed and 77 said i have
never well i have never even thought to
do it so now maybe that number will go
up maybe people are inspired to do it
who knows
just not me all right
next we've got a story for anyone out
there suffering from a little
post-divorce dating anxiety never
thought about that before but once you
exit one marriage you're out there in
the world it must
follow you around well i guess you
haven't had to think about it well i've
never been divorced um so
we'll we're going to get into it uh
inside hook says if you worry people are
going to judge you for being divorced
don't worry experts say many daters
actually see someone being divorced as a
plus
because you want someone who wants to
commit okay maybe it didn't work out
last time but it could this time they're
resilient and you learn lessons that
might make you an even better partner
i think it's like if you were a runner
and you didn't win one race do you stop
running no you got stronger from that
race you got better from that race i
think your failures teach you what you
need to know to go forward so i think
there's such value in the life
experience of being divorced
i'm going to play a surprising devil's
advocate maybe what
i i get it i get why people might look
at someone i have three divorces under
my belt and i understand if someone
looked at me and was like is there
something wrong with her
i kind of get it and i if i met a man
who was thrice divorced i might be like
what's that all about and
until you really get to know somebody
and their story you don't know why and
it can seem like too many notches on a
belt and
i don't judge people for judging it
i thought you'd be real hippie-dippy
about it but i think that that's
i think i speak for everyone but i i
actually find that so refreshing because
you do come at it from your point of
view listen we have someone in the
audience actually and i was excited to
get their take um jaina uh you're out
there uh dating after a divorce
what is the vibe has any surprises
occurred what's your state of mind and
heart i am really big into the dating
apps and and being honest in your
profile and putting it out there and and
at first i agree with you it was kind of
intimidating to admit that i have a
divorce under my belt i felt like i had
a big d across my forehead d for divorce
d maybe for damaged goods um but then i
realized i'm so
fabulous that the good things about me
outweigh any kind of negative
connotations that being divorced might
have
uh i like your spin on it you seem
confident and i will say one thing
people pick up what you put out there so
if you're like i've been divorced three
times they're like oh god but if you're
like yeah dude my journey is what it is
and i wouldn't be who i was without it
they're like oh
okay
and so i like your attitude because you
are defining and setting the tone
so i congratulate you on that yeah and
cute shoes
and you're so stylish and beautiful and
hot
just because you know you might not be
hot to trot
um you know for a partner i am the
ultimate romantic
i love talking about love and if there
is one person in here who is not
contending with a relationship of some
sort then we're probably not alive you
got a sister a mother a brother a cousin
a coworker a friend come on aren't we
all dealing with relationships
i saw something that i wanted to share
with you that reminded me of the
definition of romance and it's a tip
from the sunny side handbook
oh this is just a little tip on how to
squeeze the most out of that lemon of
life and it comes from the one and only
helen mirren that's right people reports
that she posted this pic of dancing in
the rain in venice with her co-star vin
diesel may helen mirren be the grandest
reminder to us all that if it's raining
outside and you have the opportunity go
dance in it create that romance and
poetry in your life every opportunity
that you get it reminds me of a quote by
an author i love isaac dennison
the cure for anything is salt water
sweat tears or the sea so when it rains
throw your arms open and your head back
and dance yes true
[Music]